so all four of nevada's congressional  representatives they have won reelection  however  as hector mentioned some local races are  still too close to call  and that includes the hotly contested  race for state senate district six  democratic senate majority leader nicole  cannizzaro leads republican april becker  by just  800 votes now senate district 5  even closer democrat christie watson now  leads republican carrie anne buck  by just 173 votes and a flip  in the race for clark county commission  district c as well  democrat ross miller now leads current  las vegas city council member staff ross  anthony  by 500 votes eight news now is your  local election headquarters stay with us  for updates on all of those races on air  and online  eight now dot com